denelson lament back on the hill for the
san diego padres and what a welcome
sight this is mike it most certainly is
uh he's got to be raring to go he is
prepared um last season 12 starts for de
nelson
opponents hit 161 and we've said it all
along when he is healthy
he can do uh wonderful things
and a swing and a miss just wave to that
pitch and nelson lumet has his first
strikeout at 2021
and that is not a replay from last year
the slider from lumet that's a dandy
that's some tilt right there that has
got some tilt to it it's exactly where
he wanted it he said he got the sense
from then that if he kept pitching he
was very likely headed for a second
tommy john surgery oh two swinging a
miss lumet gets garcia to chase a slider
that one almost more horizontal than
vertical either way it gets the job done
a lot of guys will swing underneath that
so 38 strikeouts to the lefties with
that slider and chalk up another one
three strikeouts in a row for lumet
we're scoreless padres you're coming up
that's adrian hauser yeah four start for
hauser 314 his earned run average last
time at he took a loss against the
pirates four in the third five hits
three runs he's making his second career
start against the padres
to his season there's a hangar that is
popped up
and jace peterson will squeeze it three
up three down go the padres we are
through one in san diego we got action
29 pitchers so far through the first two
for lumet
not sure what to make of that it's kind
of a wait-and-see type situation nelson
lumet leaving after two innings today
left today's game with right forearm
tightness
unless it's you getting rung up but not
so much
swung on and missed there's a first
strike out of the day for adrian hauser
yeah pulled the string on him good pitch
one looking for that one
no change up going away
very similar movement
to that of his fastball going down and
away from a lefty one-two to kim
swing and a miss he got him good sinker
inside
and that ends again a couple of
strikeouts and a zero put up by adrian
hauser in the second we head to the
third in san diego no score 35 career
games against the brewers a 341 average
ops at 905 and home runs three of them
16 rbis for carrottini
line to right and it's going to get in
caratini's thinking two
garcia's throw goes that way it's
offline and a double starts things here
in the bottom of the third inning for
the padres and victor caratini
well we just showed you the number is
carratini against these brewers that's a
two-seamer from austria that leaks to
the middle of the plate so in a
scoreless game you got a runner on third
one out top of the order trent grisham
it's over four in last night's game
against his former team waiting here
swings hits a ground ball through the
left side that's a base hit that's a
one-nothing pod great lead drink grisham
an rbi single against his former team
great disciplined approach
by trent grisham just trying to get the
ball hard on the ground not trying to do
too much with it gets it through that
left side to get the padres on the board
nice to break the ice jesse
after my second pitch after the
adrenaline rush and stuff i was like i
am done
and once again this is just me me
talking
just over the outstretched glove but
manny from right to throw not in time
wow
that was close
we'll see if they're going to review
this kim couldn't get it but machado and
his
arm out there in right field could and
the throw
made it very close with hosmer covering
what a great play by manny going away
from the play a short hop to hosmer he
picks it stay tuned hold all tickets on
this one
just when you think you're going to mark
it down as a base hit yeah he clearly
looks safe right there opportunity here
for jace peterson with two men on two
man out in the fourth inning at petco
park
and there's a base hit down the left
field line narvaez rounding third he's
heading home and jace peterson delivers
a two-out rbi single as robertson moves
over to third and we're tied at one how
about that i mean that's a beautiful
at-bat by peterson fastball he's able to
fight it off down the line
and omar darbaya is able to tie the game
that run will be on the record of craig
stamen fastball up slices it down the
left field line and ties the game that's
a nice piece of hitting by peterson
staying right on it
line down the left field line that will
get in
mckinney into the corner to play it pro
far into second sliding with a lead-off
double
got on top of it
that's the high two seamer so i
mentioned earlier in the game to get the
hauser you gotta get him up in the zone
and that's exactly what he did try not
to pull it just taking it where it's
pitched he could smell double
i want two
on the ground slowly hit to first
vogelback will tag the bag and then the
back door from third comes profile to
put the padres on top two to one
rbi ground out for carratini
and taking third of the play as fam
padres have their lead back
he's in the air lafayette mckinney on
the run makes the catch
there he is again
as machado
he's been making hard contact throughout
the course of this first month and he
barreled one up and mckinney able to run
it down
it took a good angle on it he's playing
deep out there and left
made it look easy boy he's got good
speed he really gets a good jump
thank you
and now
they will advance they will be able to
advance is yeah because carratini tried
to stop himself on the throw back to the
mound
and the ball just leaked over toward
third and shaw said thank you very much
does it hit the bat
it does hit the bag there you go okay
first i thought he just tried to stop
incidental contact
gurus with a chance to tie this game in
the top of the sixth as narvaez might do
more than that sends one way out of here
gone
over the right field wall omar narvaez
his third bomb of the year
and a lead change in san diego three to
two brewers
he has been
really good to start the season and his
power numbers
that ball
that got small in a hurry
well you talk about centering look like
a curve ball that was up in his own and
look at this extension gets it on the
sweet spot it's 3-2 to peterson
swinging a fly ball deep to right again
drifting back pro far another one here
in the sixth
peterson goes deep it's 4-2 brewers
second in as many days for peterson
inning magic for the cruise offense
[Applause]
and peterson going back into the dugout
and asking for a little ovation from his
teammates nicely done any behind an
account with it and having to come in
with a fastball
there it is back-to-back change-ups
takes care of caratini 0-2 pitch on the
way got him on the change-up
the air bender from devin williams the
bases are loaded for san diego
tying runs suddenly is in scoring
position for tommy pham box burger the
stretch 3-2
struck him out looking fastball outside
corner one gone brewer is trying to
protect his 4-2 lead one out bases
loaded in the eighth inning isn't
already payout pitch on the way
he struck him out
fastball blew past him for route number
two
by horizon trying to get his team out of
a major jam in the eighth inning here it
comes
slider got him did he go yes he did
jp
[Applause]
back to back strikeouts three balls two
strikes
runners at second and third with two men
out of the knife
brewers clinging to this 4-2 lead at
petco park
he struck him out went up the ladder
gets hosmer swinging as the brewers
sweep the series in san diego what a
pitching performance by this pitching
staff and how about the brewers bullpen
today and throughout the series
unbelievable i mean hasbro swings at a
pitch about neck high
he decided he was schwing and came up
empty and the brewers sweep the padres